the hem three things you can't live
without Pizza television the Internet
[Music]
and the time it takes this dog to escape
name for male singers go John Legend
Michael Buble Pharrell and Elton John
[Music]
John Legend Michael Buble the time it
takes this dog to make a splash name
four things that make the gifts the time
it takes this Rhino to break his twig
name for sports played without a ball to
play without a ball hockey hockey
there's the puck yeah javelin Oh running
swimming Bernie any time it takes this
dog to pop his balloon to him three
things you can't live without Pizza
television
no man is what she falls under the
category of the time it takes this cat
to give up poor cat mom name for website
Twitter Instagram Facebook the target
takes his dog to drop his stick name for
seth rogen movies the lion else's dog to
lick off the yoke what's wrong with this
and the time it takes this cat to make a
leap of faith name three famous english
people go throw a napkin
q grand Sasha Baron Cohen punish people
with the time it takes the dog to ascend
to the ceiling oh no name for absolutely
Total Recall die hard die hard to die
hard with a vengeance
I faster yeah and the time it takes this
dog to steal a sausage name three things
beginning with Jay jerks I know I did
something yeah it's fine it's a double
timers for life oh you're not still
watching the city
[Music]